[Music]
[Applause]
pro football focus
has put out its list of the top
50 players in the nfl now i'm going down
the list a little bit here
and uh i agree with a lot of the names
that are in here
i was surprised at a few names that were
in here some
a little too high some a little too low
i have a real problem with josh allen
being the 40th
best but i i want to have some context
here because we're all about context
uh steve palazzolo pro football focus
senior analyst
host of pro football focus the nfl
podcast
all right give me context here steve of
how you came up with the 50 best players
in the nfl
yeah the context behind it is
essentially all positions are created
equal just for this exercise we're not
worried about positional values you know
obviously if we were it'd be all
quarterbacks and that'd be it so
that's the first step and then it's
looking forward it's looking to 2021
so it's taking not just last year but
you know multiple years of information
and then saying okay who are the best
players going forward based off
everything we know
um and again not worried too much about
the quarterback being the most valuable
player on the field
okay what makes aaron donald number one
on the list
he just we great every player on every
play dan and he is just dominant you
know from a pass rushing standpoint from
a run defense standpoint and it's been
like that for
you know since he entered the league
he's been the highest rated interior
defensive lineman
every year since his rookie season uh
and he just does it all and it's one of
those things that shows up when he when
he plays 800 900 snaps it shows up
uh more than in more than just sack
totals and tackle numbers
he's just the most unblockable player
that we've ever seen really in the pff
era
then you have patrick mahomes two travis
kelsey
three quentin nelson four davonte adams
five khalil mack
is six tom brady seven bobby wagner
eight george kittle nine
aaron rodgers ten
um i can't put brady that high
wagner i like but you know like khalil
mack they're not playing in
really meaningful games give me your
rationale give me your right chanel
yeah so with with brady you know he was
our number two graded quarterback last
year now it was behind aaron rodgers but
again we're taking body of work so if
you
yeah until brady really shows physical
decline
he's our highest graded quarterback not
only you know of the pff era but of the
last four years of the last five years
so we gave brady the nod there
okay uh with wagner it's really a tough
time for linebackers in the nfl
offensive coordinators are just
attacking linebackers that everything
that they they're spending right now
this entire offseason thinking of ways
to make bobby wagner and other
linebackers lives miserable
but wagner has been the clear top
linebacker in the league since lou
kieckley retired
and a guy like khalil mack is similar to
aaron donald it's just the down to down
consistency
the sack totals might fluctuate a little
bit but as far as just winning
one-on-ones
and being a force in the run game that's
where khalil mack shines every year
give me your biggest surprise it's bryce
callahan
the uh does anybody know bryce callahan
here the cornerback for the denver
broncos
look so early pff era we did this back
in we started this in 2008 and chris
harris of the broncos was like the first
guy where we kept grading him well
grading him well and
people started to catch on maybe this
guy's pretty good bryce callahan could
be that next guy he has graded well with
the chicago bears
with the denver broncos he's done it in
the slot he's done it outside he's only
five
nine 188 he shouldn't be that good but
we grade production
and he's just been really productive
every time he's been on the field
i the one that stood out more than
anything else is josh allen is
40 on this list and and i don't think
anybody was more valuable to their team
last year than josh allen was
what am i not seeing he was fantastic
last year
again i think you just have to take the
entire body of work so if you look at
josh allen
he was he was average to below average
his first two years last year was a
legitimate
breakout season so um the fact that he's
even on the list after being a below
average quarterback probably the 28th
30th best quarterback his first two
years in the league
i mean i think that's just a testament
to how much he's grown in the short area
intermediate area his accuracy decision
making has gotten better so
look alan was fantastic last year i just
think it's let's see it for one more
year you know is he going to regress a
little bit
or is he there is he an official
superstar and if he is
he'll be in that top 10 to 20 range
probably next year you got dak prescott
at 50.
um is that is that higher than you
thought lower than you thought
honestly i i think it was it was close
between dak between lamar jackson
if if another quarterback didn't land on
the list i wouldn't have been all that
upset
um i think there's i think there's a
cut-off between the mahomes brady's
rogers and russell wilson's of the world
and then again josh allen kind of in
that gray area
i think it is a big year for lamar to
maybe you know get back to that mvp
caliber itself
but with dak i think what we've seen is
he's played when he's been on the field
the last two years the best football of
his career
trending in the right direction i think
we saw how valuable he was for the
cowboys last year after he went down
so a lot of things for dak pointing
toward him
moving in the right direction to be that
top seven or eight quarterback moving
forward and this is based on a body of
work
yeah so if it was just based off of last
year
how would this how different would this
list be yeah and so we do a list
you know at the end of the season that
is just looking back it's like here's we
do a top 101
and it's just the two you know 2020
season josh allen would be much higher
you know so dak obviously wouldn't be on
the list he only played the six games so
um yeah it it multiple year sample sizes
do matter
right and the way a guy's trending or um
but but also not overweighing too much
of one year so i think there's a lot of
guys on this list where it's like hey
just
prove it for one more year and then you
know you might be uh moving up the list
for next year
yeah you know i i love quentin nelson
and uh i thought that that would have
been enough for
andrew luck to stay but but it feels
like quentin nelson's going to the hall
of fame
yeah he's funny because as soon as he
came out you know so because we do
you know some analytics and we we grade
tape you know we we have a little
battles with the offensive line
community that thinks you know maybe you
don't know exactly what the offensive
line's doing
quentin nelson's the one who kind of
like brings us together the
offensive line gurus love him the
analytics love him
he grades well he finishes plays um he
was outstanding at notre dame yeah he is
he is on a hall of fame track he's been
the highest graded guard since entering
the league in his three years if we
looked at this right now of guys who are
hall of famers right now is aaron donald
a hall of famer yes
or no right now yes absolutely patrick
mahomes
yes he will be no right now oh right now
i think mahomes is already yeah he's
been a
star i'd say no travis kelsey
i think kelsey is okay quentin nelson
you can't say now for
only three years for a guard i would say
no right now okay devonta adams
i'd say no right now there's too many
good receivers in this era khalil mack
i think mack is yeah we've got big body
of work
bobby wagner
yes him and keekley are the two best
linebackers of their era
zack martin not yet
no deandre hopkins
oh man i all the all the receivers are
tough man there's so many productive
receivers right how do you separate
those i don't know if hopkins actually
is
now are we using opinions or
calculations
when you're coming up with these with
these lists yeah so it's based off
again we grade every player on every
play we put a grade out there we can
look at one year grades multi-year
grades
um it's not it's not automated um but
it's using that as a foundation
and then there's a little bit of uh
intelligence that goes into you know how
are guys used
how often have they been on the field so
it's based off pff grades with a little
bit of
uh our own intelligence over the top
when putting the list together give me
your top three most talented teams
right now well the bucks and chiefs
definitely have to be up there and then
the cleveland browns
are up there when you talk about just
pure
roster management the cleveland browns
have done incredible work
uh offensive lines outstanding good
group of playmakers they've they've
rebuilt that secondary which which
really hurt them last year
the browns have very few weaknesses as a
roster
the bucks are clearly in their own you
know realm as far as
they don't have any weaknesses they're
running it back from the super bowl year
the chiefs are a little top-heavy with
their stars of course with mahomes
kelsey and
tyree kill and the but the browns are
one of those teams that's just so good
all around and one of the most talented
in the nfl the least talented team in
the nfl is
i think the well the texans the houston
texans detroit lions
are battling for that they're both
rebuilding so they should they should
trade deshaun watson if they can
based off all the moves they made this
offseason yes i mean the texans are two
years removed from being a playoff team
last year they fell apart because the
defense was horrible and yes they should
definitely
they're in full rebuild mode in houston
and they signed about
you know 20 you know mid-tier type of
free agents this off season so
it looks like uh more of an expansion
team in houston right now
where do you label rank kirk cousins
i i i rank a lot of quarterbacks in that
middle tier
and it's it's kind of like the old like
number three starter
in baseball you know a guy that eats up
a lot of innings and one year he can win
15 games another year you can win 10.
i think with cousins and a lot of the
mid-tier quarterbacks when you get that
good group of receivers when you get
that good offensive line they'll produce
and
cousins has always had a nice group of
receivers so he'll produce at a top 10
type of level statistically but i don't
think you're asking kirk cousins to go
and
carry your team like you are some of
those top tier quarterbacks so he's in
that middle tier like i think maybe 10
to 12 15
other quarterbacks are uh being a former
minor league pitcher
i'm curious what you think of spider
tack and
all of the uh substances the how did you
cheat
is what i want to know steve when you
were in the minor leagues i did not
cheat enough because i didn't make it
out of the miners dan i mean
i hated having any sticky substances on
my fingers i hated it i didn't real i
thought it was just a little bit of help
for grip that guys used it for and then
i didn't realize it was an increase in
spin rates and all that stuff so i i
consider it a missed opportunity
um a good scuffed ball was nice though
for me because it was good for my
splitter you get a little
crazy movement on that if you get a nice
scuffed ball not that i ever did that
intention but who scuffs it
it's more of a luck thing like if i
wanted to okay you know you throw a
little sandpaper in there but every now
and again the umpire keeps a scuffed
ball in there and you get it and you
just put it in the right spot to get
that extra movement
but a catcher can help you your third
baseman
could have helped you right yeah yeah
you get some of that i again i never i
never intentionally did that which is
why i never made it but yeah
if if you want to scuff you just you
talk to the right people the statute of
limitations is up steve you're good
like you know you can tell us how you
were cheating true
true not enough again apparently i i
didn't man the spider tack stuff i want
to go throw right now yeah i know
what it looks like i know uh hey great
to talk to you again thanks for joining
us we love the
work that pro football focus does thanks
steve thank you dan steve palazzolo a
former minor league pitcher and
apparently an accidental cheater